good morning uh before we start if you
could please join me and Rising for the
Pledge of
Allegiance I pled the flag of the United
States of America the
for na godible with liberty and justice
for
all with that we'll open up our
continuing series of hearings on the
bail um this morning I believe we have
someone here from the defense bar and
someone from the bail fund are those
folks here
yet um who are you from sir
you may go ahead and approach if you'd
like it's my understanding um you'll be
giving us some testimony this morning on
um how and what if any bail reform would
affect the bail fund and how it
operates
yes good morning I'm PA and traso with
the New Hampshire Community Bell fund
and thank you uh for hearing my
testimony today
uh the New Hampshire Community bail fund
began in 2018 where a 501c3 charitable
organization designed to free pre-trial
neighbors who didn't have enough money
to pay low cash bail and uh we offer
rides when possible and the project is
funded by a Grassroots bunch of
donors all members are volunteers and
listening um listening to Prior
discussions about Bell reform we asked
well what what is bail reform uh when
bail reform came out in 2018 we had no
business at all but by 2020 we were
doing bails left and right 2022 we have
192 bails averaging
$428 per baill 2023 as of
926 we've done 215 bills averaging
$331 we have uh2 15
bails and we've paid bails as low as $25
50 so people will be incarcerated for
for
that most of the jails we uh deal with
72% of the jails are in uh Hillsboro
House of Correction another 10% marac
maybe 4% in Rockingham 3% Chester County
and we're kind of slowly expanding
service throughout the state but uh
Hillsboro County is the is the
biggest now most of our cases that are
referred to us they referred by public
defenders sometimes private criminal
attorneys and they generally know our
bail limits so they don't send us higher
bail cases our limits have ranged from
$250 to $2,000 depending on how much was
in the fund and most clients are charged
with misdemeanors trespassing
shoplifting possession disorderly
conduct driving while licens are
suspended and many are arrested because
of outstanding warrants also common
scenario someone was arrested on a minor
charge two years ago well uh and missed
a court date later they may have got
sober or they're have work but they
ended up in the wrong place at the wrong
time and the police ran them and they
found the outstanding warrant and lone
behold they in
jail and many of the people we assist
are on the housed some are living with
family others couch surfing with friends
other folks get taken to treatment
centers uh for
sud and you know these people are being
locked up on minor charges even though
they're in some cases legally innocent
in fact you know some of the charges of
the offenses that they're held on
pre-trial if they were guilty there
wouldn't be a uh a jail sentence to the
offense and then we we find that uh a
lot of our uh folks are me have mental
health health issues along with
substance abuse and we think what is
needed is stable housing Medical Care
substance abuse treatment instead of
jail we need to find a way to redirect
some of these people if we can carve
them out and and try to get them out of
the caral system and may try to get them
into a Health and Human Service System I
think that would be that would be solve
quite a few things that it will clear
the court dockets I mean because I think
the uh the court dockets are jammed with
cases like this and uh and I don't think
what's being done for these people in
jail is proper uh even with short jail
stay stays people can lose jet uh jobs
housing situations mispp and get taken
away from family
responsibilities uh we had one situation
where there was a couple who uh there
was a outstanding DV charge on the books
that they had resolved and they're
living together and uh one gentleman he
got jailed because of violating the DV
charge um so I bailed him out two weeks
later the wife is in jail for the same
thing and so so it it was something that
was never
cleared yes and then they have a seven
Monon old baby living at the nashille
soup kitchen so uh you know these are
some of the stories that we we keep you
know we have given people rise they've
shared stories with us we have uh you
know kept a repository of these stories
because we think some of the things that
are going on with these lower-end quotes
unques crimes are uh irre approachable
and uh we got to think of some some way
to change it uh if I can interrupt you
for a second do you have a list like
that that you could share with us of you
of these stories that you've kept we can
put that together actually I think one
of my colleagues Olivia has that okay
that' be great if we could all we could
either send it to electronically or yeah
sure however
yeah so you know the the effects of jail
I think a lot of mental health experts
feel that you know going to you know I
know the jails are looking to beef up
their mental health capacities and their
uh substance ofuse capacities but some
of these people are are only in jail for
like maybe 30 days so you got to ask
yourself what kind of program for these
folks are is really effective you know
you really shouldn't be going to jail to
get for mental health treatment or
substance abuse treatment yeah uh you
know it should just be a back stop and
the other thing that we find out is that
a lot of the folks that are in jail it
takes a while to get their medication so
a lot of times they miss uh their
medication cycle and uh it's kind of
disastrous you know being incarcerated
and and not having your medication on
time
so that's pretty much my statement uh my
other colleagues have other things but
do you have any questions for me um yeah
if I could if I'll start um have you had
an experience with any of the pre-trial
uh services in any of the counties it's
my understanding that we heard that some
of the pre-trial services are pretty
good about hooking people up with mental
health and things like that um I we've
heard about them um I think hillsbor
county is still trying to build that
capacity M but uh we're kind of like
remiss to get too involved with a pre-
child servic we don't want to be hired
by them yeah so we we don't really want
to become part of that system but sure
uh I think some of those things can be
good things okay and and do you have a
program within your organization where
you refer people to services for mental
health and substance abuse well we have
um we go through the Public Defense
venders and we do uh talk to a lot of
the different providers out there and
but usually
um uh we don't have any like formal
program set up but there is a lot of
different there it's fragmented with me
mental health and also substance abuse
yeah uh providers and if if a public
defender is saying you know take them
here I just we take them there you know
we're going to yeah we're not going to
get in the middle of that I I think the
the committee um is is very interested
in the concept of of diversion um before
they get into the criminal system the
question we have is you know where do
they go um I don't believe that there's
any facility with enough beds to to
house mentally ill or substance abuse
patients on the scale that we're talking
about so are you aware of any programs
that are open that just wishing they had
people sent to them yeah I um I know
that there's a community reinvestment
program that's being driven by uh one of
the Court people in the in New Hampshire
Court system yeah and I think they're
they're attacking that problem uh
they're looking at the people that are
kind of like the frequent flyers for
these you know low-end defenses and uh
trying to figure out what can be done
you know realistically we don't have
that kind of capacity and we just have
to figure figure out how to build it and
you know I know the criminal justice
committee and that might not be their
perview but you definitely I think I
would love to have their support in and
in putting something like that together
yeah I I believe I can speak for the
committee and that we we agree that U
mental health um mental health and
substance issues don't belong here but
but we don't know where they do belong
so we we want to be able to find a way
to to stop that but I'm not sure what we
can do yeah and I think one of the
latest studies they've done uh the
criminal justice uh organization
throughout the state has figure out like
73% of the people in jail either have
some kind of substance abuse or mental
health yeah type uh and to your earlier
Point um it's my understanding that if
somebody's for example suffering from
schizophrenia and they go in jail and
they don't have their medication they
just spiral out of control and then they
end up being cut back loose with no
medication and right they end up shortly
back in right yeah right there's not you
know there could be you know heavy
recidivism uh if you know if they miss
that those kinds of Cycles so and any
other questions from the
committee are you on our committee I'm a
substitute I don't well then go ahead I
don't
care you can be a member for today go
ahead
yeah I think Mr Newman had a question
represent Newman had a question
first yeah I was just getting ready to
thank you
um I just the process of how people get
to you and whether is there a
differentiation between uh the days of
the week when someone is arrested and
when they get arraigned and and whether
they have this problem with bail or not
it's random we kind of hear from public
defenders or sometimes they come through
our website but more often than not it's
public defender you know I might have
an email after this meeting that there's
somebody that needs to be bailed out
thank you
yeah representative sitech did I don't
see any other
questions how many people show for court
have you lost do you lose bails yeah we
we took um
uh the stats on that and we get about
85% people come back we make it clear
when we talk to them that it's important
if you want to help somebody else uh
show off a court of course there are
people that just jump and don't come and
but but one of the problems is the court
system is so slow that it takes a long
time to get the money back do you do you
um do you keep track of your bailees to
the point where like for example there
are a lot of unhoused who won't get
notices in the mail or any such thing
like that do you try to remind them of
their dates or anything like that we try
to do that but it's very difficult
because if you are unhoused it might be
a you know families in transition or
asash soup kitchen and then there's
different different places that people
are living outside it's it is difficult
to we have heard that um other places
have tried a text messaging reminder
system from the courts um and it's been
fairly successful is it your experience
that most of your baes at least have
sometime of a cell phone yes yeah it is
um however a lot of times when they get
out their cell phone you know the the
cell phone's been s sitting in wherever
and the battery's dead and they have to
recharge it but um but yes I think a lot
of them do have cell phones and that's
uh I think that that'd be a great idea
okay thank you um any more questions
from the committee representative Stone
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question on the bills that you
provide a service for what percentage of
those are victim crimes versus crimes
against the
state uh are you talking like
misdemeanor versus you have felony yeah
versus felonies or a like a domestic
violence type of situation I'd say about
70% are misdemeanors and then maybe 15%
domestic violence things and then the
felonies are very kind of are not too
common but we do get slow bails for some
felonies yeah thank you you um you had
mentioned that um business died off um
right after the 2018 bail reform and it
seems to be steadily increasing again um
any any idea why that is that you've
heard yeah our research came and this
this is interesting because around 2020
we got a um a message from the managing
partners of the public defender saying
kind of asking if we were still in
business because in 2020 there was an
omnius Bill where they kind of gutted
the Bell Reform Bill and that's why
we've gone from you know last few
meetings I heard people talking about
Bill reform like it was something that
really existed and I'm looking looking
what Bill reform you know we're bailing
people out left and right you know so
what change that you aware of I think
they I have to go back and read it but I
think it enabled judges to uh take
people who were on warrants people who
had like uh didn't who didn't show up
for trial you know those kinds of things
if there was like a minor infraction in
that process then um in
the and then they that gave warranted uh
uh bail but you know again then you
think that bail is being used as
punishment and not as you know unless
it's for an outstanding fine right
that's another question so if there many
people are bailed and the amount of bail
is what they owe do you bail those
people and if so do you ever recoup your
money yeah well basically we we pay the
court and um and the bail the bail money
goes to the court when they show up for
trial then the money comes back to our
fund no I I think what I'm saying is
like a judge will say okay you owe $75
in fees if you get picked up your bail
is $75 that $75 goes to the court and
doesn't come back because that's the
outstanding amount you owed do you ever
run into that um yes I we think we we
we've paid some fees where somebody
didn't pay child support and those were
like fees we just helped the people out
it was like 50 bucks or 75 bucks and we
said Okay okay so you knew going into it
that that you weren't going to get that
money right yeah we kind of know where
when I think the only times we really
get the money back is when we pay a bail
a full a bail at the court and you know
the bail commissioner fee if we pay a
baill commissioner we're not going to
get that back either so okay how often
do you pay the bail Commissioners uh
We've we stopped we during the week we
go to the court only because uh we have
to wait for the bail Commissioners and
the way it works is you got to go to the
jail announce yourself and then wait for
the bail Commissioners to show up okay
and so now you're waiting two or three
hours and maybe maybe little longer and
uh so we figured it's just much better
for us to go to the court okay so you
don't generally bail out people on
weekends uh no no we unless it's like a
a dire need you know okay all right
thank you and we had some situations
where we did try to bail people out on
the weekends but the bail commissioner
wasn't available I see okay thank you um
if you could give um do we have we don't
have any pink cards or do we have one up
there if you can find a pink card um I'd
like your contact information so that we
could reach back out to you sure and if
you could remember to send us that
information from the anyal studies you
had we'd appreciate that too thank you
for your
testimony and who's
next sure come up to the
mic I just wanted to um amplify a
question that Paul
your question um Sarah whitw from naswa
okay and um what the peop tell me when
they when I give them rides is that
sometimes well number one they're not
assigned a public defender immediately
so they could be in jail Friday night
and maybe the public defender isn't
assigned to them till sometime in the
following week then the public defender
has to have the time to talk or look at
their case and then ask us so they could
be in jail for a week before we get a
request for the release so people are
there for quite a long time often
because the the assignment of Defenders
they don't have enough Defenders so
sometimes they have to farm it out or
the or the Defenders don't have time to
get to them so they're in jail a long
time often and you were talking about
before their Defender can request the
bail hearing and and and get the bail
set well no the bail was set but the
defender they would they don't often
have a lawyer when bail is set MH so
there's no even there there it could be
unfair that the bail could be set higher
than it would be if a lawyer was there
yeah and then the lawyer the lawyer
isn't assigned to them until sometime
later and it could be I think sometimes
up to a week before the lawyer is
assigned and looks at their case and the
lawyer is the one who would refer them
to you yes which is why there's a gap
into yes I mean sometimes we do get
family members involved but generally
it's for higher amounts but for these
low amounts nobody asks us except for
the public defenders to help okay thank
you very
much good morning my name is Andy offet
I live in conquer so I also a member of
the baale fund group and I'm an attorney
as well and um so I want to do a couple
things today um I'll I'll be brief is U
I just want to give some examples of
some people were bailing out I know you
had asked a lot so these are these are
real life examples and just kind of
reading you know a quick description so
here's someone you know uh uh held in
Rockingham County House of Correction
$200 cash bail for a be misdemeanor DUI
chart so as you know be misdemeanors
there is no jail time uh for that uh and
here's someone is held on $200 uh cash
bail which they you know can't afford as
they're they're uh reaching out to us if
I could just interrupt real quick um a
lot of those
cases that you're going to or that the
one you just read for example was that
the initial arrest or was that those
fees that why was the $200 set was it
set by the bail commissioner or was it
set at the court I believe it was set by
the bail commissioner so as as Paul
alluded to you know we first find out
about things is from the attorney so
this was so this was from an attorney um
I I think over in Rocky yeah so this was
from a public defender who was referring
the case to us so I believe all of these
I am reading to you are um that we are
getting them uh after the bail
commissioner has set the bail they're in
they're in jail and before the court
okay before the
court so here's another one um I have
like six or seven of them and so here's
one that that theft bu unauthorized
taking so someone stole $50 of
merchandise uh has been incarcerated
when we got this email for a month that
they were picked up on 12 2822 we're
getting this email on January 25th 23
$300 cash BAS bail so again that uh
unauthorized taking $50 being held on
$300 cash bail that uh here's another
one and we get a lot of these are
Criminal Trespass uh um he's already
been in prison a month uh in jail a
month so $200 cash bail and you know a
lot of these are homeless as Paul talked
about um that uh here's one as you
mentioned earlier that uh so 250 cash
bail theft by unauthorized taking
pleaded guilty but did not pay
restitution so someone being held on
$250 cash because you didn't pay
restitution which I really don't know if
we have you know debtor prison if we
should be holding people uh for cash
bail for not paying uh not paying their
restitution um we get a lot of these you
know so this gentleman uh a
non-competent homeless harmless so this
is in the word of the attorney you know
har harmless black man who is repeatedly
targeted by police in charged with
resisting arrest been held in Valley
Street for six days $600 cash bail so
homeless uh you know been repeatedly
targeted but $600 cash bail that another
one uh held in cheser County House of
Correction uh for $50 cash bail that
that Criminal Trespass resisting arrest
you know these are sometimes the most
frustrating ones because for us because
it's $50 you know this person has no
money and you're just holding them for
$50 cash
bail um that uh um come back to this one
that uh um here's one where uh and I
know this is you know there are a lot of
moving parts to these folks in their
lives so this is someone who is uh had a
superior court charge that was uh it PR
personal recognizance so he could go to
a residential substance abuse treatment
but being held in marac District Court
for $2,000 cash bail so again you know
I'm not sure what happened in these we
don't know what happened but for some
reason the bail commissioner you know
set $2 $22,000 cash and the superior
Court's already releasing him PR to go
to residential
are those two different two different
cases this is the same person it's
probably two different cases yes okay
yes so um and as you know there's a
story behind all of these and so um that
uh another one you know being held on
$50 cash bail on a a b Mr meaner case um
that uh here's another one that that
that $50 for driving air for suspension
charge so that um you know and I have we
have a long list of these things and uh
it's just uh um so I will say I I see Mr
Larry here this morning morning that
that I've met him many times at the at
um in BOS and he I will say he's
friendly he's helpful and I we always
pay him the $40 so whenever we see him
whenever we're there we always pay them
the $40 so I guess my my um that that my
questions to the committee or things to
think about you know is is um is what
types of training do the bail
Commissioners have you know I don't know
if this is the most recent I found
online the bail commissioner handbook
from
2016 so I don't know if this has been
updated but you know okay so so 2020 so
there's the most recent one is 3 years
old that um you know it clearly says in
the handbook I'm sure it says in the
2021 that that bail commissioner should
find and I quote the least restrictive
form of bail which will ensure the
defendants appearance in court the
safety of the public and the accused
rights to freedom and I just think as I
read some of these examples that in in
my opinion and I am a defense attorney
so they know have my biases but that
that these folks who are being held on
$50 or $100 or $200 are neither a a a
Flight Risk I mean they are homeless or
not going anywhere they are not a safety
to the public and and and uh it really
is very the huge rights to Freedom so I
just wonder you know I guess my
questions you know you know around
around training that consistency you
know we see we see a lot of these baales
we're going to provide you data there
really is no consistency between bail
Commissioners between parts of the State
uh and you know and I just don't know if
this manual is updated that uh just so
you know and I'm sure so the whole
process
you know I think one of the things is
most frustrating is that the the
defendant has no advocacy at this bail
setting process I I assume you know that
the person is arrested the bail
commissioner gets charged in the middle
of gets called in the middle of the
night usually to come to the police
station and my understanding is they
talk to the police I will say I talked
to one bail Commissioners this is only a
data point of one and literally the
conversation was when I walk in I ask
the police how the person acted was he a
jerk if he's a jerk I'm going to make
his bail higher that you know if he
cooperated maybe I'll make his bail
lower you know has nothing to do with
what we talked about with Flight Risk
safety to the public um and I and it's
just very concerning that these folks
have no there's no one advocating for
them they can speak for themselves maybe
but there's no one who really can speak
for them and represent them um that uh
at the same time I know lawyers don't
want to get called in the middle of the
night either so so um but I just think
that uh the system is calling for you
know possibly more training and more
consistency you know in in in baale
setting so um I can stop and take
questions I wanted to address also one
other completely different subject on
the the bill 38 I can do that now or do
it after your questions go ahead so um
if I understand the bill so this is the
one that's going to change the burden of
proof um for I guess it's for baales
from clear and convincing to
preponderance of evidence and I guess
the one thing I I uh caution against and
this is from my own experience is that
um so in the state prison at the parole
board so for parole revocation the it it
is preponderance of the evidence but as
you know in Criminal Court it is beyond
a reasonable doubt and I've had two
clients already that have been they're
on parole from the state prison they've
been picked up uh for something that uh
in the criminal justice system the
charge has been dropped because the
state cannot meet the burden of of
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt however in the
parole board because it's a lower
standard they are found guilty and they
do have to serve time and stay prison so
so they're violated on their original
parole they're violing on the original
parole they get like a 90-day setback
you know it depends what it was but a
90-day setback so in essence you have
people who are um who are uh having to
serve another 90 days in state prison
for something as far as the criminal
justice system is concerned they didn't
even do and they're not being charged
for because the bird is higher so I just
think it's tricky to have two you know
so as you know even for many of these
clients these are criminal charges it is
it is beyond a reasonable doubt I know
you you know clear convincing it's a
current Stander which is slightly below
but I just think it's dangerous to take
it too far below because you could have
people being held on bail because it
meets the preponderance standard but not
having not going to be incarcerated
because it won't meet the criminal
standard a Beyond A Reasonable Doubt do
that make sense what I it does um I
guess the the debate would be at what
point does the Beyond a reason doubt get
triggered and it doesn't until you're in
front of a jury or a judge for a trial
right um and and you have of um the
possibility of be incarcerated on this
it's a question of being it should be
Flight Risk or danger Flight Risk or
danger and if those are the two
standards the it's debatable whether
preponderance right when we get into
dangerousness I don't know that um
keeping at a higher standard you have to
balance between the safety of the public
and the rights of the defendants so it's
a it's a tough tough conversation we'll
be having yes yes yes as you know you
just don't want to be incarcerating
people pre-trial for something that when
you get to trial it's probably there's
probably not going to be prison time for
agree anyway I know I bounced around a
lot so but I'm happy to take questions
any questions from the commit uh
representative Stone thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question I'd
like to go back to the class be
misdemeanor for DWI were there any
circumstances that were unique in that
case that you're aware
of I don't know I mean we literally you
know that um that uh and again I know
there's so if you could see so the this
is the whole message we got from the
public defender you know that good
afternoon I represent a client who's
currently held in Rockham County House
of Corrections $200 cash bail her
charges a misdemeanor B DUI charge for
which she cannot receive jail time to
send her she would be convicted and then
they give her name and docket number and
that's that's all we that's all we know
about this follow up on that yeah uh I
guess thinking back a Class B misor
really doesn't care any jail time and I
know that state of New Hampshire in the
last 20 years changed it from a
violation offense up to the class B but
in addition uh the only foreseeable
circumstance I might possibly see is a
defendant that refused to cooperate with
either the bail process or the booking
process at the time of arrest due
possibly to intoxication I didn't know
if those factors could have been at play
in this case so I guess I'd say I have
no idea but I guess I would just push
back that even if they did not cooperate
with the bail commissioner is is the
next step you're going to say that this
person's you know because the criteria
is Flight Risk and safety to the public
so I guess is the Assumption going to be
if someone does not cooperate with a
bail commissioner that they are a risk
of safety to the public because I don't
make that leap and so I still don't see
how how if they are you know less
cooperative and I will say you know it
is it is very intense for these people
to be in a police station in front of
police uh so yes sir just as a quick
followup maybe we could hear from the
bill Commissioners to see how they
handle those individuals that refuse to
cooperate with the officers of the Court
yeah okay
yes sir I just have a quick question you
you had a lot of cases and you were
referring constantly to bail
Commissioners do you get much business
when it's a judge that makes these
decisions so again that that most of our
uh Outreach is from the public def
public defender so many times sometimes
what will happen is that um the bail
will be set very high the the the they
will the next day or two they'll get
before a judge the bail sometimes the
judge will lower the bail and then
they'll reach out to to us to pay the
bail if that answers your question so we
don't yeah so um it's it's all driven
our process is really driven by when we
hear from the public defender we need
help for my client thank
you so just to follow up on his question
just so the committee understands the so
someone will get arrested say on an oui
Friday they're in jail they get to court
they're held they get to court on Monday
um they're reigned or further bail
hearing um until an attorney is is
assigned one may get just assigned by
Thursday Thursday he may look at the
case and then he'll request the bail
hearing and at the bail hearing he may
get it lowered he may not if he gets it
lowered to within your your uh ability
to pay then they'll reach out to you
that's how you get
triggered so the whole thing the way the
way we find out they reach out to us so
many times attorneys will decide that
they don't want to go before a judge
they just you know will'll get emails
that uh that my client's being held on X
dollar bail that uh I don't think it's
worth it to go before for a bail hearing
can you help us bail them out okay so
it's really the attorney one driving the
bus I'll say also we like to have the
attorneys involved that um that uh
someone to mentioned had asked a
question about when people show up and I
think by having an attorney it kind of
you know the attorney's going to keep
track I forget who asked a question
about the text you ask question about
the text message so attorney's going to
keep an eye on these clients too
attorneys want their clients to come
back so they're going to help us
uh you know you know keep an eye on
track down the clients make sure they
come back so they don't generally refer
people to you that they are pretty sure
are going to be a Flight Risk and that
you could lose your money well we I
guess we hope not but our goal is to get
as many people out as pre-trial
detention as possible okay that's our
goal and and we work with them and uh
and as Paul said you know 85% success
rate you know people coming back to yeah
do you receive any um any Public Funding
at all from the state we are all
individual we are a so it's through uyu
action that the um and we are a
501c3 yeah and we everything is by
individual donors okay thank you we
would like to get Public Funding if uh
if you have an idea for
us wrot for ideas you're in the wrong
committee for that oh sorry okay could I
just ask to repeat the organization
again yes so it's uh so the uh so we are
called the New Hampshire Community bail
fund so we have a website if you want to
go find us and we are part of the uu
action it's called uyu action which is
part of
the thank you unar University action New
Hampshire
yes and um just for anyone listening
since you are 501c3 I would imagine all
donations are tax deductible correct
thank you for the yes represent did you
have a question yes I did yes sir um you
mentioned that homeless people are are
not a Flight
Risk I I would think a person that
doesn't have a house or doesn't have any
property and you're looking at senters
for time they would just take off to
another place and start over again
another state or another County so I
don't have data to support that our
experience is that people who are
homeless they don't have any I mean
they're not going they don't have the
they're not going anywhere I mean they
don't have any money for anything they
they they can't you know so they're just
trying to eat and live and pay their
cell phone bill I'd say that many people
have you know the cell phones a high
priority so I personally again I'm a
defense attorney so you could take that
I personally don't think homeless people
that they're the least Flight Risk I
would think a person that had a house
would be le least flight flight L they
have a house they're not going to take
off because they're looking at a
sentence for time so we could debate I
just that that you need means to you
need means to flee and if yes so if
there no means there's literally I mean
they literally have zero money so I
don't even know sort of like walking
walking somewhere I don't know how they
would even get there yeah I think the
days of the hobo riding the rails are
long past I think that is yes sir yeah
um no further questions thank you for
your testim thank so much okay do we
have anyone here from the defense
Council okay great you can come
up okay all right sorry good morning
sorry I was a bit late uh my name is
David
Rothstein um I am here uh as a
representative of the New Hampshire
Association of criminal defense lawyers
personally um I was with the public
defender for over 30 years uh including
being one of the directors of the
program I am now practicing um criminal
law privately in exiter I have um I've
been here before some of you look
familiar to me um and I I would I think
most like to take your questions in this
format rather than plow over ground that
you've already plowed over um to try try
to answer some questions that that may
be on your mind I think that's probably
the most valuable I I mean I guess just
a couple things that really come to mind
quickly I our belief my belief is that
this the bail statute is is not really
the to the extent there's a problem in
the administration of bail and and I I
personally don't really think that there
is and I can explain why the statute is
is not the problem and adding more
language or taking more language out of
the baale statute is not likely to
produce anything different bail is you
know bail is it's in part governed by
Statute um and there are certainly the
the flight and the the risk of danger um
in part it's driven by a few things it's
driven by the the training the
experience the life experience of the
people who administer the statute those
are prosecutors those are defense
attorneys they're judges their bail
Commissioners I I I was in Rockingham
County court yesterday waiting for a
case I listened to to a judge do a
couple of bail hearings of people in
jail both of those people were
preventively detained uh but very
thoughtfully so after presentation from
defense after presentation from
prosecutor um after questions there's
there's been in in past sessions that
I've sat in this image that people are
just sort of released uh no matter what
they're really dangerous and and the
judge just releases them I I believe
that if if this committee had the
opportunity to listen to various bail
sessions around the state I I I don't
think this committee would have the
impression that that is generally what
happens I think this committee would
have the impression that there are
certain circumstances where an
individual is released and sometimes
I'll be sitting there thinking to myself
boy what's the judge going to do here is
the judge going to release this person
or not um and there are certain
circumstances where the person is not
released but it's done so um after a
thoughtful and careful consideration of
the facts and circumstances as brought
to light by the various people involved
I I will say that it can be very
difficult as a defense attorney to get
some of these cases um you can be
notified by the court at 11 o'clock that
there's a A felonies first or soon not
to be felonies first but there's an
arraignment on for 1:00 uh you talk to a
person at the jail you try to get as
much information as you have um I I I
don't really like that I'd like to meet
the person I'd like to have more
opportunity but even then I do frankly
feel like whether I win or lose the bail
hearing I I understand why I won the
bail hearing and I understand why I lost
the bail hearing so I I don't think that
we have a system that is fundamentally U
broken um it's never going to be perfect
because it's going it's administered by
you know by by People Like Us who are
going to make some mistakes and those
mistakes can be un either side they can
be releasing somebody who probably in
retrospect should have been detained
they can be by detaining somebody who
probably in retrospect should have been
released those things are going to
happen um resources I think could be
brought to bear uh there's been
discussion in the past about Community
Corrections programs about how sometimes
uh those programs can allow the court to
feel more comfortable releasing somebody
who would other otherwise might have
some uh reluctance about releasing um
there's a a situation I had in in
straford County recently a gentleman who
was in a really bad way using
methamphetamine primarily um committed a
second deegree assault domestic um he
was initially released on Community
Corrections and he did not do well he
did not report he got arrested um he got
brought back to jail we get an order
from the court um that he was only to be
released again if he was able to get
into a program um I talked to him he was
committed to getting into a program
there's a woman at the straford county
jail who in conjunction with community
corre Corrections got him into a program
he just completed a 28-day program he's
now released again on Community
Corrections so a county that doesn't
have those types of resources he'd
probably be sitting in jail this this
entire time and instead he get treatment
and you know fingers crossed he's
hopefully going to be out and if that
works then when his case comes up for
resolution he's going to present better
to the court and it may not be necessary
to incarcerate him either at all or for
as long as um otherwise might have been
necessary so I do think that
there are various ways in which
resources can be brought to bear um
failures to appear um all different
types of circumstances there are some
failures to appear where the person um
has lost contact with with the court for
a long time and it becomes to the court
fairly clear that if we don't detain
this person we're never going to see
them there are other situations where
the person has circumstances where they
didn't make it to court um they are
perhaps battling a substance use
disorder um as the gentleman before me
said I I I don't believe that people who
are homeless or most indigen clients
they don't go to Brazil um they don't
have the means to to flee the country
they're not that devious they're simply
people who are struggling with a lot of
problems and when they miss Court
they're not going very far and for the
most part they are not creating uh a
danger and they are not a True Flight
Risk I understand the frustration that
the police have have expressed when they
feel like they're arresting people on
you see and get released again um some
of those people should be detained some
of them should be released and try to
get them back on track and try to get
them into a program and I think if you
lay eyes on somebody if you're a judge
and you look into somebody's eyes and
you look at the defense attorney you
look at the prosecutor I think you're in
a a better position to make that
decision than us who don't see the
proceeding um and don't don't understand
all that was brought to bear um at any
time if anyone has any questions please
feel free to jump in sure um I would i'
like to comment on the portion of the
statute that purports to create um very
strong presumption of detention based
upon the offenses that are committed
there's a whole list of offenses from
first-degree murder down to some other
types of offenses human trafficking and
the like if it's murder there's a
separate statute that accounts for that
there's a separate detention statute
there's
no there's no real great I don't think
it's even possible for somebody charged
with murder to just be released without
um being detained initially under 5971 C
if the penalty uh the maximum penalty
one could receive is life without parole
they fall under that statute and there's
a whole separate procedure these other
types of cases I I understand the
inclination to say if you're charged
with something in particular there
should be a presumption that kicks in
and the federal statute does this to a
degree but you could have somebody
charged with burglary that's not on that
list that should Darwell be preventively
detained you could have somebody charged
with aggravated flon of sexual assault
maybe it occurred allegedly back in you
know
1998 um maybe the circumstances under
which it was reported are you know need
to be examined maybe the person has no
conceivable contact with the alleged
victim and is otherwise not a Flight
Risk not a danger to anybody else so
aggravated FL sexual assault is on that
list but that particular person it may
be perfectly appropriate for a bail
Commission or a judge to look at the
circumstances of course taking into
account the nature of the offense which
I think the court always does in set a
personal recognizance bail instead of a
a presumption of a A detention so I I
don't think the Endeavor to create the
label of the offense and match it to the
person um is necessarily productive um
and I think the offense is a something
to be taken into consideration if with
dangerousness it often comes into
consideration based on the nature of the
offense and the circumstances but I
don't I don't think it's necessary to
have um a statute that that tries to
sort of micromanager cherry pick
offenses and make those particular
people not eligible or as eligible for
bail um we support bail Commissioners um
we think they perform an important role
um we don't think it's particularly
realistic to have a system where you're
going to have prosecutors judges and
defense attorneys um at any hour during
a weekend that are going to be coming in
we think the bail Commissioners are are
going to continue to be called on to
support that role uh we would also
support their uh training we would
support their independence from
influence by undue influence or or exp
parte influence of police or defense or
anybody else um we see them as being
quasi judicial officers and we would
support them being paid not having to
rely on if a defendant uh coming in at
3: in the morning has 4 $4 in his pocket
we would support them being paid in a
reliable um way if we're going to commit
to them which which I think fairly I
think we're we're going to uh we support
a clear and convincing evidence standard
as to the determinations of Flight Risk
and and danger uh we think that standard
is appropriate given the um consequence
um that's going to to to occur as a
result of the imposition of the of the
bail um so those were those were my
comments I mean I have other things I
can say but i' I'd be glad to take any
questions the committee has thank you um
I'll ask a
couple so what is in your practice is it
mostly felonies that that you take that
you deal with um I have I have
misdemeanors too and misdemeanor
defendants are held on bail yeah no I'm
just curious as to what your Day-Day
practices most felonies and misdemeanors
um and there are some misdemeanor
defendants held on bail and some felony
defendants not that subjectively to me I
say gezz that's kind of odd yeah um so
that's yes felonies and misdemeanors
okay um and as far as um clients who are
out have have you seen many of them have
electronic
monitoring and to what degree could you
talk about that a little bit because I'm
interested on that as an alternative in
some cases the electronic monitoring I
think first of all I think you need a
Community Corrections program that can
administer the monitoring as you
probably know there's I think you I
think you have to have a third party
that that um is in charge of sort of
maintaining it and and providing the
signal if I'm the if I'm the monitoring
officer providing the signal that Joey
is not where he's supposed to be at a
particular time so um there's a cost
involved um it does happen in community
correction situations I think it most
often is something that is employed in
domestic violence cases where there is a
concern that the accused may have uh
contact or come within a zone of
protection um around the UN alleged
victim it's not so much as I understand
it I don't think it's implemented so
much in Flight situations I think it's
implemented more in danger situations
and you know you need the you need the
infrastructure you need the the the
funding and you need to have a person
who can pay the weekly cost of it which
I don't remember what it is but it is a
cost to some people I know that it's um
used extensively in some other states
Massachusetts for example for parole and
I believe they have a a company that
does oversee it and notifies the parole
officers hey your your client is uh just
removed his thing or a lot of times the
conditions of parole will be you're
allowed to go to work and go home and
yes things like that um it's usually
tied yes it's usually tied to other
conditions a curfew you can't go like if
you know the the alleged victim works at
the Haniford in Rochester you can't go
go to the hord in Rochester so if if if
there's you know if you know the the
accused there's a you know he's within
the zone of the Haner and Rochester
there's a way to to to do it they'll set
a Geo fence that'll KCK geofence correct
so it's usually tied to a curfew or
other types of
circumstances um I think it's effective
um I was actually it's funny I had a
hearing in federal court yesterday and
there's a new technology where um it's
something called start link and it's an
app on your phone and they send you um a
uh random messages at random times of
the day and if you don't get back to
them in 15 minutes with a photo of
yourself where you are then that
triggers um basically the the your
supervising officer to take action so
that was something that was discussed
that's apparently coming through the
pipeline um electronic monitoring I I
don't think it is I don't think the
concern is generally that the person is
going to be at Flight Risk but I suppose
that's possible too if you have a Flight
Risk concern and you really think that
somebody's going to go to Logan and
catch a flight to Bolivia then yeah that
would that would be something that could
be used for that I would just be
interested in the cost versus the
incarceration um you know if someone's
on that and they're worthy candidate for
it they'd be able to go to work and go
home keep their job yes does that cost
more or less than incarcerating someone
and and the effects of it well
definitely it's got to be less because
as I understand it the cost um the cost
of the well the cost of paying for the
the the monitor is
paid the the the the defendant has to
pay a weekly fee now in terms of the
cost of what does it cost straford
County for example to set up the program
that would be an interesting question I
can't tell you that but that that would
be an interesting question and it would
be interesting to hear from a place like
straford County on the effectiveness of
it do you only see it is it is it depend
on what county you're in who will be
using that and who doesn't yes it it is
dependent on what county you're in as we
love New Hampshire but it's very um very
different from County to County right um
if my my understanding is if you don't
have a county that has a I mean meramac
has a Community Corrections program I
know that straford does chesher does
there may be a few others but if you
don't have a Community Corrections
program then it's um I don't think you
can do the electronic monitoring and I
don't think you can really do elaborate
bail Supervision in other words in those
counties I think the judges and
prosecutors and defense attorneys are a
little more hamstrung in terms of the
options that they have okay so we need
to look into look into that and it's as
you know it can be it can be hard you
know when it's a county bycount thing uh
because you hear from the different
delegations and they've got their
different priorities I I honestly I mean
I I've have practiced a lot in straford
um and I think straford has been in many
ways for alternative sentencing has been
held up as a model and I think for this
Community Corrections program there is a
it's probably the most cohesive and
chesher as well is probably a very good
place to look for a sort of model I
would like to see their um their bail
violations versus Hillsboro for example
the right the people who are part of
that um Community Corrections versus
people who are not and I would say I
mean in a place like Hillsboro I mean as
you know demographically it's it's it's
tougher place than you know Manchester
is a tough place there's no question so
Nash though so they yeah different uh
yeah um and I think I think that um you
know but I I I think if you had uh in
Manchester it would be interesting that
if you know that the Manchester
especially the circuit court has a
historical reputation for overly
incarcerating people um whether that's
born out statistically that's certainly
the anecdotal evidence um it would be
interesting to know if they had some
other Alternatives in that county
whether or not they would consider not
doing that um um you know and you know
if a person is is without housing it
would certainly be easier to get in
touch with them that day to even have
the you know the person monitoring them
drop a you know drop a reminder like hey
while I'm talking to you remember you
have court in a couple days you know
yeah um so okay thank you any other
questions
from thank you thank you if there
anything you else you think of that when
you should know you can email it to the
committee very good and any other
questions feel free to contact Cather
and or and I'd be glad to answer them
okay thank you um 11 o' we're going to
take a 15 actually we'll meet back at uh
11 oh I'm Sor go ahead represent may I
address the committee you may indeed um
I'm I've been looking at the I want to
say training and consistency everything
else I say now you can ignore they are
the big pieces but as I listened to the
conquered attorney uh Paul ly and I are
about to fly around the room there's a
couple things I want to say please first
you started this whole series Mr
chairman by saying we're going to get
this straightened out once and for
all
haha we have to try but that's a I don't
know that we're going to hit that goal
I'm going to take that as the part I can
ignore but go ahead the other thing is
just as a matter of vocabulary I heard
this and attorney has left but
felons go to state prison jail is pre-
incarcerate incarceration House of
Correction is post conviction just
terminology
look I've the 22 years 3600
baales I believe what the uh the bail
commissioner's handbook says about the
least restrictive I've never set a cash
bail on a bee you can't do that all du
DUI get out on PR it's just a fact of
life um I don't know where I'm not
denying him but I just I I've never done
that I've been I've been scolded by my
clerk I must be a defense uh bail
commissioner because I've been scolded
for letting them out too easy I would
have given a higher B what what are you
talking I have to do the least
restrictive that consist that the
circumstances
allow uh about homeless long ago that's
settled you bail homeless that's the
other thing it's never happened but I
was told in one of our seminars which we
having October 18th Rocky amp County for
the bail Commissioners that even if he
doesn't
cooperate he's still entitled to bail
and I I write if you want me to not
answer I'll put refuse to answer you
tell I'm sure the judge will like that
it's as far as I go
but the worst I've gotten is you don't
want to give me a cell number something
like that
uh I started off training in consistency
that's so big by the way I've told told
this story I bailed this just it just
the timing in because it land landed two
a week
ago aggravated sexual fonal assault a
natural father on his do 12-year-old
daughter he did
things I bailed him under PR no criminal
history no allegation he ever did
anything like this with her before it
was a visitation he has no contact with
her there was no indication that he he
was I don't know if contrite but subdued
he
knew the if I jailed him and I know what
the news if this gets in New newspapers
if I jailed him it's punish Advanced
punishment it's not anything it did not
fit the circumstances of this situation
however
loathsome the Act was yeah as long as
the victim is protected then there's
really no there was no question about
any of that and or his stated
cooperation and there was no reason the
police didn't even want it okay so
please I'm going to leave every body
with training and consistency oh my God
that's what we want and just to um for
on behalf of the committee or myself um
my goal is to fix it once and for all so
haha but I set lofty goals and it's
better to set them high and not meet
them than set them low um also your
experiences as a bail commissioner um
our our our hearings have brought
forward and and shown us that are just
yours because because we were seeing
different experiences for every bail
commissioner so that brings us back to
training inconsistency um and with
regard to the list of um cases that the
the counselor brought what we don't have
is the back story I mean did the person
have an extensive record were there
other outstanding warrants they're so
complicated every case is complicated so
you have to take each individual before
you as they come and since the bail is
set thusly um but thank you for your
input as always did you want to add
something before we take a
break you get one bu at the Apple
though I'll just bring one of those nice
big Golden Delicious good morning my
name is Paul liry I am a bail
commissioner and I've been here before
you several times just to not pick on my
learned counsel but just to go along
with some of what he said it sounds you
know terrible but I think you hit the
nail on the head Paul Javy page two the
rest of the story if it was a DWI
misdemeanor
B if he had shown up in court he
probably wouldn't have had a cash bail
because he would have been released on
PR bail and the reason he comes before
the bail commissioner is because DWI has
subsequence offenses as you commit them
and jail then becomes a possibility so
therefore that's why they're they're
bailed but typically almost all of them
other than they might be put in
protective custody because they don't
have anyone that wants to come pick them
up and they spend the night in the jail
and sleep it off and some of the other
things just listening to what he was
listing most of those typically it's not
the bail commissioner bail commissioner
does just a little bit and when you see
2550 and $100 usually not a bail
commissioner that's usually a judge
that's wrestled with it looked at
homelessness and other things and is
looking at what is something that could
be a possible deterrent but not the
thing that's going to reasonably keep
them in jail cuz they set a $10 bail but
the guy didn't want to post it after
about nine months collection was taken
that person was bailed out but that was
their choice but a lot of them is he
said are there because they don't have
the money homelessness doesn't come into
play however if they keep failing to
appear they end up with breach of bail
contemp of court and those take those be
misdemeanors of violations and bump them
up up to a misdemeanors which are
jailable offenses hence that's where the
problem comes the theft statute if you
know it's shoplifting and they take them
under the theft
statute when it's the third conviction
it bumps from B misdemeanor a
misdemeanor up to a felony level offense
and again creates another problem
especially if they don't go to court and
that's most of the challenges and many
times when I see him there it's because
they've already been before a judge
we've got the bail orders from the judge
and it's just a matter of exchanging
money do the bail bond and he's on his
way it again it's not the bail
Commissioners having the final say and
anything that happens to somebody on
Friday night or Friday afternoon
afternoon time it's the luck of the draw
because nobody works in the system the
bail Commissioners are out there 128
hours a week on their own excluding
holidays then it goes up another eight
hours but the thing is it's Monday
through Friday 8 to 4 holidays excluded
so you know it just happens and it's
it's sad and as to what my bail
commissioner friend over there stated I
had one similar last
night no record no nothing but however
uh when you take a baseball bat to a
vehicle somebody's face and somebody's
stomach and it's a first degree
assault and
there's all kinds of stuff going on at
home that
says I'm not capable of making that
decision this person truly needs to be
seen by a judge because of the violent
nature of the
offense he'll be seeing the judge at
1:00 this afternoon but it's like it
just happens because sometimes it's the
nature of the offense that drives it as
well as what's going on and then when
you find the backstory of what's going
on in the house you can't return them to
that situation so again training I
support that 100% because I'm tired of
at 3 o'l in the morning trying to figure
out what in God's name we're supposed to
do because there is no Direction the
bail commissioner's manual lists crimes
that we cannot set bail on and homicide
or first second degree murder all those
things are listed in that and there's a
couple others and then there's some
caveats if they are out on probation of
parole
and they do a certain amount of things
we can't bail them they need to see the
judge and then probation and parole
probably would violate them so they bail
commissioner would not even be called
and that was in the 2016 Manual of 2020
which had been out there and supposedly
was going to be updated and they pulled
the 2020 down and it's not on the bail
commissioner's website anymore so I'm
still using my 2016 because I didn't
bother printing the 2020 because it was
online so but I mean that's the thing
when you hear stuff like that you've got
to keep in mind a lot of its electronic
bench warrants they have been seen by a
judge and unfortunately the time process
they don't find out they need an
attorney for someone at arraignment at
10 o'clock or one o'clock until first
thing Monday morning and they're trying
to jump through hoops to do it but they
also recognize they got a 5,000 to 6,000
case backlog because of Co on the court
appointed attorneys so that's part of of
their case load so there's a very small
pool available at the time too that's
another challenge um I I just have a
question before you go do you see any um
people that you bail have you seen any
of that are on electronic monitoring
when they're there uh yes I've seen some
of them but again that's nothing that
you know I've done that's something
court or pre-trial Services ordered and
I see it in marac County marac County
used to have a private company that was
doing it but recently they've taken it
in in house and they're now doing it
in-house where County employee or might
be with the pre-trial Services is
actually the one that comes up puts the
monitor on them sets it up and the
account and it's done there I don't know
where the monitoring is but that's at
merac County I can't speak to the others
okay and for the just for the purposes
of the committee who don't know you get
a a bench warrant that has conditions of
bail set you you're not allowed to alter
that
correct
for example if it says from the judge
anything signed by the
judge we do not touch we cannot change
save one item if he does if they do the
bail cash uh CTS cash to settle if they
don't have the money we have the ability
to change it to PR bail that is the only
bail that we can change cash to settle
means they owe a fine or what have you
say $500 usually like he said you know
he was speaking about debt is Court yeah
what happens is what they forget is they
sign a usually sign a contract that I'll
pay so much a week and at the very
bottom in fine print it says if it is
not paid in full by this date you will
appear before the judge on such and such
a date and time they don't show up hence
the electronic bench War for
nonappearance in
court and we go through the same thing
but it's for non-payment of fine yeah my
experience is a lot of people will sign
that because they want to get out of
jail they leave so well that's usually
at the court and but the thing is the
court has a one-page form if it's
strictly to pay fines or fees they can
wave arraignment and then if the court
wants to see them the court can then
reach out to them if they're able to pay
the money so you could change um cash to
settle that was $300 to
pr300 and give him a new give them a new
day um where they'd have to go explain
and if they didn't show up there' be
other words I give them a new
arraignment date and then they go in
before the court and if they don't show
up for
that it may just be no bail or it could
be back to an electronic Benchmark and
see the thing is what happens is where
we all don't know it's whoever the
history of the individual yeah the court
may it be wh's end with this person
because they keep not showing up and
they keep pushing the bail up and it's
not having any action so they just go to
a no bail situation that guarantees when
they Court no questions us they're going
to be before the court yeah so I mean
that that's some of the challenges
because the thing is not a lot of us
don't know Back stories yeah and I think
it's important we leave that discretion
to the judges on most of those cases
okay all right thank you very much again
for adding to you're welcome we are
going to be in recess until 11:30 at
which time we'll decide if we're going
to do anything else for the
day wait minute I don't think I was
supposed to say what he says there one
of those words we not supposed to say
what is
it
thank you everyone um at this point
after confirm with the committee members
and um our witness list we're going to
uh call it a day tomorrow morning we
have someone coming the superintendent
from Rockingham is going to give us some
information on what they're doing um
what can be done and um we'll go from
there next week we have some um some
people that come in that run pre-trial
in various counties that will be able to
tell us you know what the gold standard
is and what they're doing and what maybe
it costs and what the potential is for
us to maybe implement it Statewide and
what the cost of that would be so I feel
like a lot of what we hear are these
small crimes and people not showing up
and this is something that I think that
a pre-trial system would be able to
manage and keep their eyes on people
whereas right now people are just in the
wind and then they end up with these
recurrent failures to show up and things
like that so that'll be for next week so
tomorrow we're going to have the
superintendent from
Rockingham and I think there might be
someone else um I have to go back and
look at my list so that's it for today
I'll see you all
tomorrow